تبداوا ليبيا العام الجديد في ختم تحركات
دبلوماسيه المكثفه وتستقبل طرابلس مديره
وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه السياعي
يبدو التحرك الامريكي لافتا لان الامر لا
يتعلق بوازير خارجيه او وزير الدفاع يلتقي
برونز رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد طبيبه بحضور وزيره الخارجيه نجلاء
المنقوش ولا اخبار عن ترتيب لقاء مع حكومه
فتح بشاشه المكلفه من مجلس النواب في
المقابل يتوقع ان يلتقي بارز اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في مقره بمدينه
بنغازي شرقيه ليبيا تاتي زياره البرنس في
سياق ما يبدو انها عوده الاهتمام الامريكي
بالازمه الليبيه فمنذو اصولها الى السلطه
ابدت اداره الرئيس جو بايدن اهتماما
متزايدا بهذه الازمه في الثامن والعشرين
من يناير 2021 طلبت من روسيا وتركيا السحب
قوته من ليبيا وبرز هذا الاهتمام اكثر
بتعيين نولان سفيرا وبعوثا خاصه الرئيس
الامريكي في مايو 2021
واظهرت انشطه النور لاند في ليبيا ان
ازمتها اصبحت من اولويات السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه انخرط نور لاند في الاتصالات
الجاريه من اجل ازاله العقبات امام تنظيم
انتخابات طالانتظارها والى جانب هذا
الاهتمام الدبلوماسي ترعى قياده القوات
الامريكيه في افريقيا
مباحثات اللجنه العسكري خمسه زائد خمسه
ياتي هذا الاهتمام الامريكي وليبيا في عهد
ادارتي بعد فطور واضح شهده عهد الرئيس
السابق دون ترامب الذي كان يعتقد ان
الازمه الليبيه ازمه الاوروبيه وليست ازمه
امريكيه
وتميزتا المواقف الامريكيه في عهده بتناقد
احيانا فعندما شلنا اللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر هجومه على طرابلس في ابريل عام 2019
اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه رفضها للهجوم
اما ترامب فقد اتصل بحفطر وناداه بالمشير
وهناء بجهوده فيما وصفه وبمكافحه الارهاب
تغير الوضع الان واصبحت واشنطن منخرطه
بقوه في جهود حل الازمه الليبيه تفعل ذلك
وهي تعرف الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
والاقتصاديه لليبيا وفي الخلف ينشغالها
بالنفود الروسي والصيني المتزايد في
المنطقه